دعنا نتحدث عن هذا -
يا جنرال التعبئة الجزئية لديك خلفية
عن كيفية تدريب الجنود الروس
وأنت تقول إن هذه التعبئة آخذة في
الانخفاض ولكن ليس لسبب
قد يظن الناس أنه يسقط الفك اشرح
نعم أعتقد على الفور أن عدد
300000 تم حشدهم.  إلى
أذهان الجميع وهذا أمر صادم أه لا ولكن
عندما تعرف تعقيدات
أخذ جنود الاحتياط وإخراجهم من
بيئتهم المدنية وتحويلهم فجأة
إلى جنود بسرعة كبيرة ،
فهذا أمر صعب للغاية عندما
يكون لديك هذا العدد خاصةً مع
الشكل الذي  روسيا في الوقت الحالي هي
أول شيء يجب مراعاته هو أين
يمكنك معالجة هؤلاء الأفراد ، وكيف
يمكنك نقلهم من حياتهم المدنية إلى
حياة الجندي ، وكيف تمنحهم
زيًا موحدًا للأسلحة
، وإعادة تدريبهم ، ودمجهم في الوحدات والوحدات
التي  لقد تم
تدميرهم في ساحة المعركة ، لذا فإن
الروح المعنوية منخفضة بالفعل لذا فأنت
لا تؤثر عليها  فقط الجيش
بطريقة سلبية للغاية من خلال محاولة إدخال
الأفراد الذين لم يتم تدريبهم أو
كانوا جزءًا من الوحدة منذ
بداية هذه الحرب ولكنك تتحدث أيضًا
عن التأثير على المجتمع المدني
والصبي لا نراه بالتأكيد  تلك
الليلة مع كمية الاحتجاجات
التي تدور في جميع أنحاء روسيا أه
وهذا شيء لا أعتقد أن
بوتين اعتبره حقًا رد الفعل
من الأمهات والمواطنين
وخاصة من الشباب الذين
لا يريدون  لنذهب ، أعتقد أنك
تحدثت عن ذلك في وقت مبكر ، وبينما
كنا نغطي الحرب ، قلت أنت وخبراء آخرون
إن هذا كان كما تعلم بمجرد
أن تبدأ في التأثير على الأمهات
وأطفالهن لا يعودون أو ما الذي كنت
ستحصل عليه هو المد والجزر  قد يتحول عندما
يتعلق الأمر بالمشاعر العامة حول ما
يحدث في الحرب ، فماذا تقول
حول مدى فعالية الجيش الروسي
إذا كان يجند
الناس ، فإنه يحصل على
مجندين وهؤلاء هم الأشخاص الذين كنت أنت
أعرف كانوا يحتجون
أه لا أستطيع إلا أن أقول إن هذا
لن يساهم في نجاح أه حتى الآن
الجيش الروسي في المراحل الثلاث الأولى
من هذه العمليات
فاشل بشكل كبير لأن
لديهم جنود غير مدربين قادة فقراء جدا
أه معدات رهيبة
وإمدادات معطلة مثل  بالإضافة إلى بنية
القيادة والسيطرة الرهيبة ،
فلديك الآن
جيش في ساحة المعركة تم
تدميره على مدى أكثر من 210 يومًا ،
معنويات منخفضة القيادة في
المرحاض والآن ستقول مرحبًا
نحن ذاهبون  لتعيين أشخاص جدد في هذه
الوحدات بشكل جيد بعد أن كانوا في
ساحة المعركة في وحدات ليست في
حالة جيدة ومحاولة
إدخال المجندين الخام على الرغم من أن هؤلاء
الأفراد ربما كانوا في الجيش الروسي
قبل أن يصبحوا
مجندين خام إذا  في النهاية يبلغون
الخطوط الأمامية أنهم لم يتم
قبولهم جيدًا لأنهم لم يقاتلوا
مع الفرق الموجودة هناك
معنويات الفرق الموجودة هناك  re
فقير بالفعل لذا فهو مجرد
وضع طبقة أخرى من النشاط الكارثي